This is a major issue,
major ratio for a,
for us or,
and I think that,
uh,
we have to move fast forward,
in developing new technologies,
which would decrease that dependence of
a western societies.
And the world as a whole,
uh,
on oil and especially oil is coming from
regions that are so volatile,
vulnerable and subject to influence of,
uh,
extremist trends.
The more we invest in finding
alternative sources of energy,
uh,
the more,
we,
uh,
encourage our scientists to focus on
this semester.
Uh,
the more responsible will be for,
uh,
for our children.
And,
uh,
I,
now wearing my hat,
uh,
as the ambassador of Israel.
This is one of the areas where a,
I hope Israel in the United States
could,
uh,
cooperate.
We've done tremendously in so many areas
that are of critical importance sport to
the United States.
In Israel.
We have,
uh,
the United States obviously,
but Israel to the best of the
scientists,
a worldwide.
And I think that we need to encourage
them to sit together and,
uh,
bring promise to the world,
that,
uh,
our grandchildren will be less
dependence on,
on oil than,
uh,
than we are.
Okay.